let's bring in though Albert Breer the
mmq be calm Sports Illustrated senior
reporter over there Albert joins me here
on the show Albert when you watch the
perfect hit again it seemed to me like
it was a textbook example of what the
NFL was trying to take out of the game
does he have any chance of getting this
thing reduced on appeal I think the
problem he has is exactly what you laid
out there which is his history you know
this happens in a vacuum there's no way
there's even a one game suspension for
this you know it's you know it's
borderline without question and you can
see how he came in from the side and
he's gonna make the argument that you
know Alex Smith pump-faked and that he
thought the ball was coming there no
matter how you want to look at this
there's no question that this is another
player he would not be suspended what
fact is this is vantes perfect he's got
the history and he has to know that the
standard is different for him you know
the same way the standard is different
for you know Elliott when he goes into a
bar the same way
the standard is different for martavius
Bryant when he's around marijuana it's
just you've got a history with you know
a certain thing and the rules are
different for you and clearly the rules
are different for Montez perfect than
they are for any other player in the
league when it comes to this stuff so
the Patriots lose julietam for the
season torn ACL in that right knee any
other team any other situation say this
is a catastrophic injury and almost a
hundred reception wide receiver but with
the Patriots don't you kind of just sort
of shrug and say wow Austin Carr it's
gonna have a great year this year with
with Edelman being out I mean how
significant is the element injury I
think you look at the two Super Bowl
plays over the last three years and you
can find it you know the hit II took
from kam chancellor you know in Super
Bowl xlix and then the circus catch the
Super Bowl 51 in both of those cases you
see a quarterback who trusts you know
his receiver on the biggest of stages
and the tightest of spots and he throws
it into traffic a trust that his guy is
gonna come away with
that's what Tom Brady loses now I mean
look they've got depth without question
they've got Gronkowski they've got
Brandon cuffs they've got they've got
Hogan I mean there there's there's depth
there there's depths in the backfield
they'll be able to make up for this and
it's not like they're not going to go
thirteen three or fourteen two as a
result of this they'll be able to figure
it out you know I think where this could
wind up costing them is in those tight
spots when they're playing for the
number one seed in December and when
they get into the playoffs where is Tom
Brady gonna go and when he's in some of
those positions does he hold the ball
for an extra second so is he taking more
hits you know I don't think that there's
some sort of overarching impact that
this is going to have where it's gonna
really adversely affect their win-loss
record but I do think there could be a
cumulative effect with Brady and I do
think that there could be some spot and
critical moments down the line where
it's going to affect them so you know
early on they're gonna have to adjust
and there's going to be that adjustment
period in September and I think they'll
be fine getting through that you know
and then I think later in the season one
you know the stakes are high you know
that's when you really sort of feel the
loss of Edelman but they're so well
stocked at those skilled positions that
I don't think much of it's going to be
knows right away target out where the
MQB calm sports illustrated' joining me
here on the Dan Patrick show I know that
Mike Glennon is dog there Albert sorry
about this is what happens on when you
move to the suburbs
I know let me ask you before I let you
go let me ask you about the Bears
quarterback situation Glennon clearly
still trenched as the starter there but
the way true Biscay played in the
preseason is the leash a little bit
shorter on Mike Glennon entering this
year yes and the answer is yes because I
think now they probably feel confident
well I know they feel confident that
they can create a scenario where they
can put miss you out there and get them
game reps and not adversely effective
development what
is really the thing that you know you're
looking for with a rookie quarterback
and I'd maintain what I've maintained
all along here you know they want to see
Mike Glennon out there they've made a
pretty sizable investment in them and
you know if they win there's no choice
to make you know if they find a way to
stay in the playoff on you know around
Halloween and around Thanksgiving then
they're not gonna they're not going to
make a quarterback change you know and
if they get to the point where they're
three and six or four and eight you know
then you really start to think about it
and so you know I think that the way you
want to look at this and the way I
looked at it going into you know I asked
me a month ago what I would have sold is
yeah I mean if they're four and nine in
December then there's a good chance that
they're gonna throw Joe Biscay in there
and get him some experience I think now
based on what we've seen over the course
of August and the work you throw in the
preseason and how they've been able to
dress it up a little bit make him
comfortable out there now I I think it's
feasible that you see that point come a
little earlier where if the offense is
really struggling in October you know
then maybe you see the ideas they get
turned to them and that's based on
Travis Keyes clay and that's based on
how he's come along and so I think
Glennon's ability to hold on to the
starting job is in large part tied to
the team success and whether or not the
team's in the playoff race because
clearly true Biscay is that the future
there I just think what we've seen in
you know over the course of the three
preseason games tells us the true Biscay
has come along a little faster than they
thought he would and so the coaches will
be a little bit more comfortable
throwing them in there if it does look
like the season is lost and they gotta
start working at they start working on
2018 hey great to visit with the Albert
go sign for that package and doubt abrir
the MQB comm Sports Illustrated joining
me here on the Dan Patrick show the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience